con un encuentro histórico así empezó la
segunda jornada del papa en irak
escoltado por un convoy el papá
francisco fue hasta la ciudad de nayaf
para reunirse con el gran ayatolá ali al
sistaní uno de los máximos referentes
del mundo islámico chiíta al sistaní
rara vez aparece en público y no recibe
visitas pero con el papá hizo una
excepción como muestra de respeto a
puerta cerrada a los líderes religiosos
discutieron sobre la necesidad de
coexistencia entre el islam y el
cristianismo con un alegato de paz el
ayatolá salió en defensa de los
cristianos de irak una minoría muy
azotada por la violencia en el país tras
la reunión el papá recurrió 200
kilómetros hasta la ciudad sagrada de ur
donde se cree que nació el profeta
abraham venerada por musulmanes judíos y
cristianos allí la eminencia religiosa
habló sobre la necesidad de acabar con
la violencia y se posicionó en contra
del extremismo
hostilidad
y la hostilidad el extremismo y la
violencia no nacen de un corazón
religioso son traiciones a la religión
nosotros los creyentes no podemos
quedarnos en silencio cuando el
terrorismo abusa de la religión
siguiendo con su ruta el papá se dirigió
a bagdad donde ofició una misa en la
catedral latina de sanjosé su siguiente
paso el domingo será visitar la ciudad
de mosúl muy golpeada por el terrorismo
y la lucha contra el estado islámico
esta es la primera visita de un papá
irak y un momento histórico para la
coexistencia interreligioso